After I broke the world record prop from
payout, I've gotten thousands of DMs
asking me one question. What strategy
did you use? And every time I see these,
I laugh because all I used to do it was
liquidity and fair value gaps. So, in
this video, I'm going to teach you
everything you need to know about both
and share with you the three-step
strategy that helped me make over $4
million from prop firms over the past
four years. So, grab your notebooks and
let's get right into it. So, liquidity
and fair value gaps. Now, most traders
know these terms, but 99% of traders use
them completely wrong. And here's how I
use these tools to get real results. So,
let's first talk about liquidity. Now,
what exactly is liquidity? Simply put,
liquidity are the resting orders in the
market. Think about your stop losses and
take profits. It's where stop- losses
sit, limit buy orders sit, and limit
sell orders sit. So, large institutions
cannot enter or exit trades unless there
are large opposing orders available. So,
price is moved towards those areas that
contain large clusters of resting orders
and price moves to liquidity. Liquidity
is the fuel for price movement. Now, as
a very basic example, we're going to use
session liquidity. Now, what is session
liquidity? Think of session liquidity as
the clusters of orders that form around
each major trading sessions high and
low. So, for the Asian range, that's
going to be from 8:00 p.m. Eastern to
12:00 a.m. midnight Eastern. The London
range is going to consist of 2:00 a.m.
Eastern to 5:00 a.m. Eastern. And the
New York range is finally going to be
from 8:00 a.m. Eastern to 12:00 p.m.
Eastern. Now, when you're trading index
markets, just remember that the equity
open is not until 9:30 a.m. Eastern. So,
your New York range might be from 9:30
to 12:00 p.m. So, over here, we have the
Asian range. So, we have our Asian range
high and our Asian range low. Now,
during this session, there are going to
be buy and sell orders that are being
generated above the high and below the
low. So, anybody going long during Asia,
it might be entering in here and putting
their stop loss below the low or maybe
their take-profit above the high. So,
you're going to have resting limit
orders above and below those old highs
and lows. And same thing with London.
We're going to have our low and our
high. And we're going to have resting
orders above London's high and below
London's low. Now, why exactly is
session liquidity so important? Because
sessions create predictable liquidity
targets. And price is not moving
randomly. It's being delivered from one
session's liquidity pool to the next.
And this is why you constantly see Asian
highs and lows taken by London, London
highs and lows taken by New York, false
breakouts at session boundaries, and
reversals immediately after a session
high or low is swept. Now, think about
it like this. Most retail traders are
unprofitable. And the way that
institutional traders and professional
traders operate is that they're trying
to be counterparty to those losing
traders. So instead of you placing your
stop loss at the low of the Asian range
low where most people get are getting
stopped out and if you're bullish on the
market, you're trying to buy those stop
losses from those losing traders and
you're trying to be the counterparty to
anybody that's trying to sell into those
lows. So here's a very quick graphic
example. Let's say this is our Asian
range and we have sell stops resting
below here. Well, smart money is going
to try and accumulate their longs
of those Asian range lows and target the
Asian range high. Okay, this is where
your counterparty activity is occurring
is you're trying to participate and
enter in the market where most people
are getting stopped out. And vice versa,
if you're bearish, again, you have the
Asian range or London range highs. Okay,
most people's stop losses are going to
go above that high. And where they get
taken out, that's really where you're
trying to participate and be active in
the markets, waiting for the raid on the
opposing end of the range. Now, let's
talk about fair value gaps. A fair value
gap or FVG is an inefficiency in price
created when the market moves so
aggressively that it leaves behind an
unbalanced area where little to no
trading occurred. It appears as a three
candle pattern where the wicks do not
overlap and that signals that price
expanded too quickly for buyers and
sellers to transact fairly. Because
markets naturally seek balance, price
often returns to these gaps to rebalance
liquidity, making fair value gaps high
probability areas for potential entries
in the direction of the prevailing
trend. Now, let's quickly go over how to
identify these fair value gaps. A
bullish fair value gap exists when you
have three consecutive candles. The high
of candle 1 does not overlap the low of
candle 3. This creates a price gap
between candle 1's high and candle 3's
low. That empty zone is your bullish
fair value gap and it signals that price
expanded upward too fast and price is
likely to return to that gap before
continuing higher. So as you guys can
see here we have candle 1, candle 2 and
then candle 3. You can see here the high
of candle one and the low of candle 3,
they are not touching each other. So
whatever this price gap is you guys can
see in the body of candle 2. So we have
the high of candle 1 and the low of
candle 3. If the high of candle 1 and
the low of candle 3 are too far away
from each other and they're not
overlapping, like they're not touching
each other, then you get a gap on candle
2. And what we're anticipating is a
retracement into the fair value gap to
pick up that resting liquidity before it
goes higher. Now, vice versa, a bearish
fair value gap exists when you have
three consecutive candles. The low of
candle one does not overlap the high of
candle 3. Now, again, this creates a
price gap between candle 1's low and
candle 3's high. The empty zone is your
bearish fair value gap. Now again, it
signals that price expanded downwards
too fast and price is likely to return
into the gap before continuing lower. So
walking through this, you guys can see
the low of candle 1 and the high of
candle 3 create a gap inside of the body
of candle 2. And what we're anticipating
is a retracement into that gap before
trading lower. Now, here are just some
examples of bullish fair value gaps. You
guys can see here that all of these are
three candle patterns. So we have candle
one here, candle two, candle three. Note
the high of candle one does not overlap
with the low of candle 3. And we have
another one that forms right after it.
We have the high of candle 1. This is
very large bullish candle. The high of
candle 1 does not overlap with the low
of candle 3. There is a very large gap
inside of the body of candle 2. And as
you guys can see, we rebalance to both
of these levels before trading higher.
Again, here we have the high of candle
one, candle 2, the low of candle 3. And
inside of that gap, we get a retracement
to rebalance the fair value gap before
going higher. And another example up
here of a bullish fair value gap of
candle one, candle 2, and then candle 3.
Note how the high of candle 1 does not
overlap with the low of candle 3. Now,
there's some bearish examples over here.
I didn't mark out every single bearish
fair value gap because not every bearish
fair value gap is going to be retested
and it's not going to be picture perfect
all the time, but we do have candle one,
candle two, then candle three. Note how
the low of candle 1 does not overlap
with the high of candle three here. Same
thing here. We have candle 1, candle 2,
then candle 3. Note how the low of
candle one does not overlap with the
high of candle 3. And once more over
here, now you understand these tools and
they are very simple, but the patterns
alone mean nothing. You need to
understand context. Now, context is the
difference between being able to draw
patterns on your chart and being able to
make money because drawing out your
session liquidity and drawing out fair
value gaps can be very, very simple. To
be honest, somebody in elementary school
can probably draw these on a chart. Now,
this question separates people who know
ICT concepts from people who actually
make money with them because liquidity
and fair value gaps are tools. Again,
very simple tools, but the context is
the engine that decides whether they
work or not. Now, here's the real
explanation. Liquidity and fair value
gaps do not work by themselves.
Liquidity pools and fair value gaps
exist everywhere on your chart, but
price only respects them when they align
with institutional intent for that
session and that day. Now, that intent
is called context. Without context,
you're typically trading random
imbalances against higher time frame
order flow into the wrong session phase
during the wrong part of the day into
the wrong liquidity objective. Now, this
is why most fair value gap and liquidity
traders fail is because we're not trying
to trade every liquidity raid. And we're
not trying to trade every fair value gap
that appears on a chart. Now, let's talk
about what context actually means.
Context answers three critical questions
before you ever look for entries. Now,
first of all, where is price in the
larger picture? Is it at a premium or is
it at a discount? Is it near a higher
time frame, high or low? Is it inside of
a consolidation or an expansion? Second,
what liquidity is price currently
targeting? Are we targeting the previous
Asian range high or low? Previous days
high or low or the previous week's high
or low? And also, which session is
delivering the move? Is Asia building
liquidity? Is London manipulating and is
New York expanding? Now, this doesn't
have to be so black and white. Maybe
London is actually expanding and then
New York is consolidating. Or maybe the
AM session during New York is
manipulating and then the PM session is
going to expand. So, in summary, context
is really about building a bigger
picture. We're not just trading setups
for the sake of trading setups. You have
to take setups that are aligned with a
higher time frame idea and that make
sense in the overall market. So for
example, if NASDAQ or Euro or gold are
in a very large highframe uptrend or
bullish environment, then we typically
don't want to look for manipulation on
highs to go short. We're looking for
manipulation of the lows to go long. So
here's just a very quick trade example.
We have our Asian range low here and
I've only marked out the low because
let's say we're bearish on the higher
time frame and we're only looking for
short positions. So, we're looking for
raids on either the Asian range high or
the London high. You can see here that
we have our London high and our London
low and as well as our Asian range low.
Now, we have our London high where a lot
of traders buy stops are going to be
resting above those highs either to get
them in the market or they're using a
buy stop as their stop loss when they're
short prematurely. Now, when we tag out
those London highs and it fails to trade
higher, the market then rolls over to
target the Asian range low and maybe the
previous day's low down here. So, now
that you understand context, let's get
into the most important part, which is
the trade entry and execution. So,
here's a very simple three-step
execution model that I typically use.
Step one is going to be establish
context and directional bias. Without
that, you're basically trading blind,
and we are not trying to just trade
setups for the sake of trading setups.
Step two, we're going to wait for a
session liquidity raid, whether that's
on the Asian range, the London range, or
the New York AM session, and then we're
going to wait for a closure, which I'll
get into in the next couple slides. Step
three, we're going to execute using a
fair value gap, and then we're going to
target opposing session liquidity. So,
step one, let's say we came to the
market and we only wanted to be bullish
on the following day. Well, here we're
going to mark out our Asian range low
and then our London range lows because
we want to see either of these lows
being rated prior to our New York
session. Let's say we're only trading
index markets and we're only trading
after 9:30 a.m. What we're going to look
for is a raid on either the London or
the Asian range low, which we get. And
then we're going to wait for a closure
back above the low. Now, if we take out
the low and it doesn't close back above
in a significant manner, then we just
avoid the trade entirely. But here we
can see post 9:30 we run out the London
low and then we get this nice expansion
leg higher creating a fair value gap.
We're going to enter using a limit order
at the fair value gap. Obviously put our
stop loss below either candle 1 or
candle 2's low and then we're going to
target session liquidity or previous
days liquidity and that might be our
Asian range high. So in this example we
can see that we've targeted a 3 and 12
to one reward to risk. One more example
let's say we came into the market and we
were bullish from the prior day. So, our
bias is bullish. What we're looking for
again is a read on the Asian range or
London range low around 9:30, which we
get here. We get a nice flush around
9:30, right? But then we're waiting for
a closure back above the London low at
least, right? Because the London low is
over here. We're looking for a closure
back above, which we get here. And then
we're waiting for a fair value gap to
form. So, we get both of those. We get a
closure here above the London low, which
creates the fair value gap. Again, we're
going to enter on a limit at the fair
value gap. and then just target the
Asian range high or maybe this New York
high back here. Now, this trade setup
provided a two and a half to one reward
to risk. Here's another bullish example.
Again, we are waiting for a raid on
either the London range low or the Asian
range low when we sit down at our charts
at 9:30 a.m. Okay, so 9:30 a.m. we get
this run higher, but we don't take a
long position yet because we're waiting
for either the London range low or the
Asian range low to be rated. We get the
raid on the one and range low and then
we get a closure above and then we wait
for a fair value gap. So once we get the
raid we get a closure instantly but then
we wait for a fair value gap. Okay, the
fair value gap appears here. Maybe we
set a limit inside the fair value gap.
Our stop loss goes below either candle 1
or candle 2 and then we target this New
York high. Now this trade example
provided a 3:1 reward to risk. Now let's
talk about some bearish examples. Let's
say we came to the market and we were
bearish leading up to this next day.
Again we're waiting for the 9:30 open.
So 9:30 open, we should already be able
to mark out our London high and our
London low. And inside of this range,
we're looking for what? Again, we're
looking for a raid on the high, but
instead of you entering short as soon as
it takes it out, we're waiting for a
closure back into the range. Okay? So we
get a raid and we don't look at any
trades until we get a closure here. We
get our closure back into the range and
then we have a fair value gap that's
resting above here. We enter a pending
sell limit inside of here. And again, we
use either candle one's high, which is
all the way up here, or candle 2's high,
which is here. And then we target the
London low. Now, this trade example
provided a 4 and 12 to one reward to
risk opportunity. Here's another bearish
example. Let's say we came to the market
and we had a bearish bias from the
previous day or our higher time frame is
telling us that we want to be bearish.
We mark out our Asian session and our
London session ranges. So, here we have
our London session high. We get a rate
above that high. We do get a closure
here, but we're waiting for the fair
value app to appear. So once we get the
closure below the London session high,
we're just trying to wait for the next
fair value gap to appear. The fair value
gap doesn't appear until here, which is
around 9:30, and then we set a limit.
Now, that limit doesn't get filled until
around lunchtime. Okay? So, if you miss
this trade, you leave the the pending
order in the marketplace because this is
the setup that we're looking for. We're
looking to trade limit orders into these
fair value gaps. We're not chasing price
as it runs away from us. Okay? So, we
set a limit because this helps us frame
our risk and our entry. So, once it
comes back up to that fair value gap,
gets tagged around 11:00 a.m., then our
stop loss goes above the high of either
candle 1 or candle 2, and then we target
the next low, which is our New York
session low around 10:00 a.m. Now, this
trade setup provided a 4.38
to one reward to risk. Now, one more
bearish example. We have our Asian range
over here, and we have our London
session high over here. Again, we're
looking for a London session high read
around the time that we're looking to
trade. So, we do get a raid here and
then we get a closure, but there's no
fair value gap, right? So, we're looking
for that displacement. If we don't get a
bearish fair value gap that appears
after raiding the London high and then
breaking down, then we just wait. Okay?
Then we get another run higher here
ahead of lunch session and then we get a
trade in the PM session. So, we get
another displacement lower. we get
another closure back below the London
high and then we get our entry which is
our fair value gap. So, as you guys can
see, we are taking all of these steps
and utilizing them. We're not just
taking one and trading it, okay? We need
to have both steps one, two, and three
that align with each other. If you take
a trade just based on steps one and two,
then obviously you're not following the
system and you're not following the
process. Now, you're probably wondering,
why wouldn't I take this trade back
here? Because we get a raid of the
London high and then we get a fair value
up in here. Well, we're waiting for the
equity open because this is the index
markets. We're not trading ahead of the
open. We're waiting for setups that
appear after 9:30 a.m. Now, in Forex,
that might be 8 a.m. You're looking for
setups that appear after 8:00 a.m. If
they appear at 6:00 a.m. or 7:00 a.m.,
those are typically setups that I'm
trying to avoid. Based on my data, when
I've traded outside of those trading
hours, I've typically done pretty
poorly. Now, if we patiently wait for
this setup, it provides a 6:1 reward to
risk opportunity because we're just
targeting the Asian range low. Now, this
strategy is stupid simple. So, most
traders do this wrong and they get stuck
forever. So, I need you to do exactly as
I say and follow this process to a tea.
So, again, step one, establish your
context and directional bias based on a
higher time frame. Step two, you're
waiting for a session liquidity raid and
a closure. You're not just trading the
liquidity raid as soon as we take out a
high or a low. And then step three,
we're going to execute using that fair
value gap and then target opposing
session liquidity. But remember, when
we're trading these fair value gaps,
they have to appear within our trading
windows. If you want to take your
trading to the next level and work
directly with me, I've opened up a few
spots in my inner circle program. I'll
teach you the lessons I've learned over
the last 14 years, help you avoid the
mistakes that cost me a decade of
profitability, and trade alongside you
every single week. I'll leave a link
down in the description. If it still
works, then spots are open. But if it
doesn't, then that means slots are
closed for the next enrollment. Now, I
hope you learned a lot from this video.